there are two kinds of people in this
world people who want a cinemasins
t-shirt and people who don't know where
if you're one of the former mine then
you're in luck they're available today
if you're one of the latter legs well I
would feel bad for you except you
willingly clicked on this video which
has cinemasins t-shirts in the title so
you know you sort of had this coming
you're welcome to call us a sellout in
the comments if you like but this is all
we'll probably hear to the rest of you
we ordered a small amount of shirts to
figure out what the demand is for them
if you want one you should go get it now
they will probably sell quickly if they
sell out but don't worry
we'll make more there are three
different shirts to choose from and you
can buy them here and you can get the
link in the video's description on our
website or in our main channel page
header
[Music]
no one can